If
the next excerpt is taken from original tape W one eighty nine
side
one it looses Assange
Stevens the liberation of it and then there's the family
reunion about the son to graduate from high school you say
to a kid
today on this picture I sincerely
children a boy and he still lives within
a ready to eat
paternalistic and you can see that turkey on the table looks like
to do with the girl he just saw
happen to stop all our content today she just can't wait for that
turkey
to be caught and served well
after the stuff after the dinner that bobby soxer was
taking all the goodies of Thanksgiving dinner. They're going to be stopped all
the day just to like lay down to go met a lady sitting
down we like to waste a
little and then after a
while then I get ready to
go back to their own home. I have
to start packing again those places spent all weekend. They came from some
of those places that we had suspected and ready to go in that the crowd had a long journey
ahead of the things you see in the. Oh I see a mask in
a place a cup and stopped to take
a fork and excuse me I'm a mess. So the
pepper shaker and the clattering folk and find
their turkey on the
platter
preceded all of that big family reunion when their children.
In rushing into the fine house to quit grandma and grandpa and
proudly say when do we.
Twenty
three. I see a
mother on a child. Taking down his teddy.
Thing in down his head
is holding his hands together
to smother the scalding him.
How do they not take the stone back to school to this is we all
agree there was and we probably both assume this is only.
Called the little detail I told her that Brownie had broken his
windows mother is calling him and then going out
on
repentance. And he promises my bed that he will not do it again.
But mother makes him go to the store who have to buy the bring the paintings in here and have to put it
down all by
himself two
very angry.
For eleven.
This is a month. She's the first time. She has
been expect to have babies only in contact when she
sits in the hospital bed in the baby's.
Feeding
time. Among the reefs nursing the baby and the
baby is very very
hungry and he'll be crying and that my very soul has given
him that I just can't stop looking and he grinning
and smiling and I believe
he said. Take a long
time now the next will come and take him back to the
nursery.
Six bags to five. This is a
great boy who sat through this.
Roller skating and he had just come to the piano but has helped
me through the
Barry ice cream cone and the spray booth really makes those fall
down and shoes must do for my bad
skin color.
And she gets a great scratch on her knee and shoes.
And she's going
to run home she's going to say my me about it but this big boy has a minor.
So the Kowloon let me look through any things a little bit because we can get away
with murder that way if you keep going that way he's going to be
policeman and a good house to stay with that Rice can he come with headphones.
Maybe mother will give him the eco chic but I
still think. He's thinking hey
he's coming at her and she's
crying. Oh she's on
the sidewalk.
I don't I still count on the ground and the knee.
Real estate.
Selling fab nine hundred fourteen. And
it was about. Three man.
Real home surrounded by those wires and they just beyond one small has been
carried out. By yet through. Our roof boyfriends.
I mean I'd like to now because we can do the rock. Because we have better sound
both I believe.
And that is I mean is that. With ice
cream. And the.
Release and I feel sorry for that man that he is being carried by
his boyfriends team of the respectable men because
we lose respect. He's had a suit on and one of
his brothers and I just threw it and the other one has just
said looks like a car broke loose on cowboy boots.
He has his hands in this chair a long sleeve shirt and
exact I want a great shock and I feel sorry for that man because Bradley he's right
he's going to be racing Volkswagen with a rolling pin on her
hand.
The very day and they're like in the middle I don't
need you to hear every day and I think you failed because it was done like.
Kids but without losing them the same standards as he
is the reset button that Moses Sanders.
Probably brought to
me. They found one hundred seven.
And they had these two men. And one out and then.
Just holding a knife and a baby on her
hands. And then there's another lady she says
a national can a lady I would call her a lady. Because she was a road.
She looks as though she was my full
solution. But well her
husband has been a faithful to have
been one of the major barriers. I used to run who's going to run
so full of headway into our lives and I know maybe it's
going to prevent her from coming is assumed to have been married. Into a
mess to scale
her. So she was no ten nothing but men. I don't
know but I'm pretty soon I have been with
some type of killing
is
those approach I used to have you notice most I live.
Maybe I don't know how to do that
I didn't I'm
sure.
The president looks more like the
chinese korean the Japanese guy
says he has
been
back home to handle a
really big pie
this time spies
and he's landed a full
sized Bash on the
back of a big
fat back
then they ran by
them all loose trying to make sure my balance was on high.
But then they see some through me pushing them
away but you know
looks like. Maybe with some stuff I do know.
Maybe this is me. I've got a room to let you have a case of
one
rock the next fall even become a legal
night
dress. Just like that.
I don't think this is the romantic.
I
Pads and they
go a little higher and this is
a big city because I can see the sky clear through the red from
spires so I don't believe he's saying that a fire in
the paint as opposed to my mad be showing
his bill calls for money. The men have seen.
In the Senate Tom I read him I mean and despite the
radio play he comes out
and told him up on the mountain about to go into his
room those numbers found in the family with our back
money in his bill small talk to
him so that we could do make money lose my money
scouting already money putting up a fight and he's unwilling to
lose money so easily to the point about my I'm
doing very
well and move on then I'm the only one group of
men who
carry on the rich man's
heart rate dropped
to a
man who is very angry with Rangers got to look like his new friend in the town
and then he's going to pull something like that on
him that he is this friend now rather
than he
must listen heavily on
the number that
I'm
in the most important one the difficult ones.
Everybody getting found one body isn't the right thing to do so they
put to me saying come to Minnesota to
go shopping because if I felt so so bad that you have to do too much
fucking everybody prefer trying to set up one of the suburbs.
I'm
buying now we have
already heard from say
it isn't the right.
Ghost and they really have a Web site on
the
West already Yes I may
notice and by the
way and then we are going to stay and
he's
just
discovered the pair of the front.
This is pretty badly saved by the shell. And a bit of discrimination in
the
Amazon are set in just five minutes.
Leslie power and the University of put the pickup truck.
Well you son of the I could see some very old
fashioned
cash
in the picture after I'm sure that the background.
Comes
out
to me this removes as the way she written refinery.
And then I
found
the scene in the middle of
the Bible to
send
the Spanish king and
queen and this is a
tutu
is
that lacking just to show some of them.
I think this is
something
that to some
Jewish
nation.